We would now like to look at
some applications of the rocket
equation, in which we have an
external force plus dmr dt,
where m and r is the mass of
the rocket at time t times
the relative velocity
of the exhaust velocity
was equal to m of
r dv rocket, dt.
And now we want to consider
some special cases.
So our first example
will be a case when
there is no external force.
Now, this might be
characteristic of a rocket that
is far away from any type
of gravitational interaction
and is either speeding
up or slowing down.
This is a special
case that will enable
us to understand our problem.
Now, we'll draw a
picture at time t.
Just to remind ourselves,
we have mass of the rocket.
It's moving with a
velocity v of r of t,
and we're going to call this
our plus i hat direction.
And then at time
t plus delta t, we
have our fuel
delta, delta m fuel,
which was equal to minus
delta m rocket moving
with the relative velocity u
plus v of r of t plus delta t.
And our rocket itself is moving
with v of r of t plus delta t.
So in our coordinate
system, we have
to remember that
the exhaust speed is
relative to the rocket,
and we define that to be u.
Since the rocket
is moving forward
and we've chosen plus i
hat in that direction,
it's minus u i hat, and we
can write our vectors vr
as v of r i hat.
So our rocket equation
in this special case
becomes dmr dt, minus u i
hat, equals mr dvr dt i hat.
Now, in this equation,
remember that it's
important to recall that m
of r is a function of time.
Unless we have an explicit model
for how the mass is ejected,
in principle we can't solve
for the time behavior,
but we can look at this
differential equation
just by eliminating the time
completely by multiplying
through by dt, in which
case we have minus dmr u
equals m of r dvr.
Now, this is separable
and I can integrate it,
so I'll bring the terms minus
dmr over mr on this side,
times u, and that's equal
to dvr on that side.
Now, when we
integrate, we're going
to be integrating
mass of the rocket,
say at some initial
time, t initial,
to mass of the rocket
at some final time.
And over here, we're
going to be integrating
the velocity from some initial
time to some final time.
When both these integrals
are straightforward,
on the left-hand side
we have a natural log,
so we have minus u, natural log
of mrt final over mrt initial.
And this side, we just have
the velocity difference,
v of r at t final
minus vr at t initial.
Now, again, we always
check our minus signs,
but recall the mass of
the rocket is decreasing.
So the log of a
fraction is negative,
so we have a positive
quantity on this side.
And that's indicating that
the velocity has increased
on that side, and so we conclude
that the velocity of the rocket
at its final time is equal
to the velocity of the rocket
at its initial time.
Now, here, I'll
keep this minus sign
in here-- minus natural log
of mrt final over mrt initial.
Now, in our answer,
we need to know
what the mass of the rocket
is at the final time,
so in general this
equation is still not
going to give us an
explicit expression for v
of t final, unless we
have one special case
in which our final time is when
all the fuel has been burned.
And our initial time is the
rocket with all the fuel there,
and then this ratio
is a known ratio.
And you can look at a variety
of different examples for that.
So there is an
example of the solving
the motion of a rocket
with no external forces.